[Music]
coming up on 608 on your back to work
back to school Monday just when you
start getting used to some of those
overhead signs on the I-15 a few of them
are being taken out of service
it's the short distance on the south 15
from Flamingo down to Russell Road where
the Nevada Department of Transportation
and the Regional Transportation
Commission are relocating a cable as
part of your favorite new freeway
project that complete rebuild of the
I-15 and Tropicana we're told the work
itself will not impact your ride there
just won't be any info on the signs
starting at five this morning scheduled
to run until six tomorrow evening
I wonder how much of an impact those
blank signs are going to have I guess
we're going to all find out together oh
and by the way there are all kinds of
Lane restrictions and closures
throughout the area concerned drivers I
urge you to check out i-15trop.com for
updates a link to the downloadable app
and all of this information is on the
online version of this story at
8newsnow.com when you click traffic then
driving you crazy buckle up drive
carefully please put down that phone you
can join the driving you crazy
conversation at traffic eight at
eightnewsnow.com